he's Reggie Miller reg will be on the
call this Thursday night with Kevin
Harlan he's got the Nuggets and the
Lakers 10:30 Eastern on TNT red joining
us from Los Angeles reg how are you
today good morning Theodore I'm doing
very well
how are you I'm not panicking it feels
like you know three losses in a row for
the Lakers to open up the season local
reaction feels like should we and be in
a panic mode what would you like to say
to the Laker faithful absolutely not we
were three four games into a very long
marathon season and this is kind of what
we expected and even to the point where
Rob polenka Magic Johnson went to Luke
Walton and said hey if you guys got off
to a slow start
it's alright we have faith in you in
this team what it looks like to me is
you've got the generational type
superstar player in LeBron James and a
lot of young guys that play hard but
really don't know how to play and now
you add to it two key components being
out you know three to four games in
Rondo and Ingram I kind of think this is
what we expected the sky is not falling
that the seasons not over now we can
have this same conversation come
Christmas and into the new year if they
continue to play like this the one thing
one glimmering sign of hope that I do
see is they do play much harder than
they've played the last couple years now
the question is and I think this will be
all on LeBron James figuring out how to
win ball how to win ball games close
ball games LeBron with the big three
they found a way to push that game to
overtime but they couldn't find a way to
win the ball game and that's always a
mark of a young team and I think a lot
of that will probably bear on the
shoulders of LeBron yeah you can't blow
a lead like that you know that that's
where I mean good teams hold onto those
leads but you know I'm not I'm just
looking for sort of what is the momentum
growth that I see with the team and
that's the way I think that most people
should and will approach this but you do
have people thinking well LeBron there
should be immediate results and even
when he to Miami and went back to
Cleveland it just doesn't happen that
quickly with him know and the two places
you just mentioned had much more talent
and more veteran had a more veteran
presence than this this young team again
when you add you know a Rondo and you
add the Lance Stephenson and Beasley
guys that have been around the block a
few times people expect results quickly
that's just not the case because Luke
Walton was playing a lot of young guys I
mean Jonathan Williams I mean I was
calling his games and Gonzaga last year
during the tournament and he's in the
fourth quarter in overtime
making big-time plays so this is what
you've got it's growing pains and you've
got to understand that and you can kind
of see the you know the expression on
LeBron and the whole trust the process
it sounds a lot like Philadelphia right
and we see how that's working out right
so trust the process understand this is
a young team you're going to take your
lumps we can have this conversation if
they're playing like this January 1st
that's different but I'm gonna give them
a long leash just for the simple fact
you know I see this team all the time
they are playing much harder now than
they did a couple years ago and a lot of
times that's a big step for young teams
the Rockets Lakers fight and I was I was
surprised that Ingram only got four
games and that Rondo only got three
because if you're spitting or you're you
know Ingram with a shot from behind a
cheap shot there you know Chris Paul is
gonna get suspended because you throw a
punch there what did you make of that
entire situation number one I would
never ever advocate violence that has
never been my motto but I will say this
shi t happens things happen and I think
what's been missing in our game is we
have a collection of great stars
individual but what's been missing has
been team rivalries
well we have a team rivalry there's been
a long a decade-long history between
Rondo and Chris Paul and it's been
simmering for a while and with both of
these teams being in the Western
Conference both teams to my opinion
should be in the playoffs we have
another great rivalry something that's
been missing and yeah it was a cheap
shot by Ingram coming in behind but in
times like this if you're the Laker fans
and if you're the Lakers you find out
who's in your foxhole and I don't I
don't have a cable I don't but look I've
had my share I've been in a few of them
more than a few you find out who's with
you you wanna know who's with you Luke
Walton LeBron I wanna know who's with me
Ingram I can roll with this dude I can
roll hit my cp3 they have history good
history do you run to another do you
think Rondo spit in his face
depends on what angle you're looking at
even if you find one angle I don't need
I don't need ten if I find one no do I
think he spit in his face no do I think
he was talking and spit came out and hit
him in the face yeah yeah I don't think
he was blatantly tried to you know put a
loogie on him yeah it looks like it
looked like he was trying to you think
he won't I think there was intent there
I do fall to react that way like what
happened in that moment because if Rondo
doesn't say anything to you there has to
be something magical that happened
imagine they were okay what do you think
Rondo said where are you saying magic
what was Rondo saying or what with Chris
Paul say what was Rondo saying that made
Chris Paul take a swing you they
probably consider you the best point
guard in the league and you haven't won
that's probably what I would say to
Rolla MO see Rondo's got the chip
underneath him and that's been the one
thing he I think he's always kind of
nitpicked with cp3 yeah you're a great
point guard but can your team's win I
mean have you
past the second round until last year
he's probably saying things like that
do you think Rondo is a hall-of-famer
but that's not gonna make me punch you
do I think Rondo is a hall-of-famer uh
no I do not
okay who would you rather have Rondo or
Chris Paul
Chris Paul but I will say this Rondo in
the playoffs because now I'm wavering
because give me Rondo in a seven-game
playoff go back to backs where he gets a
chance to study the opponent
I like Rondo okay but if you want him in
the postseason that's more important oh
I gotta get there and a lot of the
things that okay does not make her Rondo
great it kind of rears its ugly head but
you know playoff series rod looks pretty
good
anybody ever spin you're like I do not
think I do not think he's more thing
about I do I think he's spent I think he
was talking noise to him and spit came
out okay and that's probably how a Chris
Paul reacted in the rest is history go
we have a great team rivalry now between
you aren't you gonna watch every time
yeah plays the Lakers now we were gonna
watch that no not really not really the
Lakers are the bodies yeah you will know
you know you had watched it but now
you're watching more in anticipation
because every move because they got a
guard one another to every move now I've
already will be watching between these
two talking to Reggie Miller coming up
Thursday night it'll be the Nuggets and
the Lakers so you know got the Lakers
losing to the Spurs and they got Phoenix
and you know this is a fun Phoenix team
you know I mean they're missing a point
guard but they're they're a fun little
team and then you got Denver and
Denver's a playoff team a little bit of
a stretch here if you're gonna handicap
what you've seen so far
Golden State obviously Houston the
second-best team who's the third best
team in the West so far well I'm gonna
backtrack a little bit cuz we talked
about this I said Golden State in
Houston yeah
I'm not sold on he's
anymore I said and I will say this now
two through eight they're gonna beat up
on one another there's only one outlier
in the Western Conference and really in
this league in that's Golden State but
two through eight there just couldn't
beat up on one another that's why if I'm
Luke Walton
Magic Johnson I'm not worried orally
because everyone's going to beat one
another I had didn't ver at number five
Lakers at number six
I think Denver's as good as to stay if
they stay healthy they can get the
number two spot I am not sold anymore on
Houston they play zero defense now as
great as Harden and Chris Paul are
Carmela does not look the same I I'm
just not sold on them I mean they beat
the Lakers barely and then the next
night they lose to the Clippers so two
through eight are just gonna beat up on
one another
so if the Nuggets can stay healthy they
can be number two I had OKC at three
they haven't won a game yet they lose at
home to the Kings last night Washington
goes into Portland and beats Portland
Memphis on the road last night goes into
Utah in wins so do I have if I'm gonna
bra and I'm looking at the Western
Conference saying what these teams are
better than us Memphis goes into Utah
and beats Utah come on that well you
know there's not many off nights that's
gonna be the key this is different than
the East when people say oh just pencil
in the bronze for 50 wins and I said no
that you don't get those off nights it
feels like you know in the games that
you're supposed to win especially at
home I you know the games early count
just the same as the games late and if
you're Utah if you're Portland you're
gonna think back to this one you know
you're gonna think back to that that
Memphis lost you're gonna think back to
that Washington lost at home when you're
trying to jockey for seeds to get home
court advantage that's why there should
not be any panic in the Lakers starting
o in three because two through eight are
just going to beat the heck out of
one another and it's whoever gets hot
late like last year in the East
Philadelphia went on that sixteen game
winning streak going into the playoffs
and they had hot momentum it's who gets
hot late and can kind of find that
rhythm trade on right now right now I
have Denver as my number two feet Trey
young going off on Sunday it was against
the Cavs but you know I'm still it's fun
to watch it feels like he's got the
green light whenever he wants it there
in Atlanta he does is that smart to just
let him go yeah it's an NBA game it's
almost like a rookie quarterback you
know he's gonna take his lumps he's
gonna take his sacks he's gonna take his
interceptions but you got to live with
that because he's learning on the fly
and you know 39 points is 39 points it's
an NBA game against NBA competition rent
it's the Cavaliers George Hill
I believe that one time was it was an
all-star was on a team that went to the
Conference Finals at one time was
calling at one time they're giving up
about a hundred and thirty points again
was it at one point it was 140 there was
40 giving up that house Malibu Malibu is
fantastic anyway show that's right yeah
we're gonna be out mid-november we're
coming out for the week and we're we're
gonna go see I think a Laker game we're
gonna see the Rams play we're gonna go
see UCLA USC we're taking all dinner so
yeah yeah I this is my little Christmas
gift to the dance we're gonna do that
maybe we'll go to Malibu and and hang
out come to Malibu so I could at least
treat you guys to lunch at least do that
for my dad's house the neighborhood any
new stars in the neighborhood of Malibu
the victorious sit
then mr. Ryan Braun returned yesterday
so that's like big news on our street
here because we were all cheer all the
neighbors like got together or watching
the game and it's sad how it ended
because we were all pulling for
Milwaukee but we're happy I'm always
happy from small markets when they go up
against Goliath but you hate the Dodgers
right
I'm an angel fans what do you think I
know I died just letting people know
that do they have neighborhood parties
in Malibu yeah but do you yeah do you go
to like a neighbor when's the last time
you in the fam went to a neighborhood
party well our party's more so consist
of birthday parties for a two and five
year olds so a lot of those which we do
go to okay but you go you do away games
too so it's not just a home game for
your your two little ones correct do you
travel to other houses for birthday
parties of course what do you bring when
you show up at a birthday party
depends on the age of the little one but
you can never go wrong and the parents
are gonna kill me on this but you can
never go wrong with cupcakes bring the
sugar because you it's almost like
dropping a bomb you bring the sugar and
you're leaving and they've got to deal
with all those I'd love to see you
parenting how patient are you as a
parent my patience has gotten much
better because that's the Virgo of me
because the Virgo is like do it like
this every single time structure and
here
instructure and we're gonna do it like
this every other time so it teaches you
patience but I have a wonderful
wonderful partner who has much more
patient and than I am but I've been
learning that I'd love to be around when
you're when you're parenting I'd love to
see how you're holding and you know
China I love my boogers I'm a grizzly
bear - don't look at them crazy oh yeah
safe travels there the Lakers and the
Nuggets coming up Thursday night with
reg with Kevin Harlan we'll talk to you
next week
Theodore you are truly the best thank
you my friend love you Dan that nahban
that's Reggie Aloysius Miller jr. the
third for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]